Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
Today we're going to do a
nice little problem involving
computing the arc
length of a curve.
So in particular, consider the
curve given by the equation y
equals x to the 3/2.
So I have here a kind
of mediocre sketch
of what that curve looks like.
You know, it's curving
upwards not quite
as fast as a parabola would.
So I'm interested in the piece
of that curve for x between 0
and 4, which I've drawn here.
So why don't you take a
minute, pause the video,
compute the arc length
of this curve, come back,
and we can compute it together.
All right.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you had some luck
computing this arc length here.
So let's set about doing it.
So I'm sure you remember that
in order to compute arc length,
first you have to compute the
little piece of arc length ds.
And we have a couple of
different formulas for that.
So then after that,
you get an integral,
and then hopefully it's an
integral you can compute.
So let's remember what ds is.
So there are a couple of
different ways to remember it.
One way, that I
like, is to write
ds equals the square root of
dx squared plus dy squared.
So this always reminds me
of the Pythagorean theorem,
so I find it easy to remember.
And then from
here, it's not very
hard to get the
other form, which
is, you can divide through
by a dx squared inside
and multiply by dx outside.
So you can also write this
as the square root of 1
plus dy/dx squared dx.
And when you write it in
this form-- it's, you know,
this is the form
that you can actually
use to integrate it, to actually
compute the value in question.
So in our case, we have y
as a function of x, right?
So we just have
to compete dy/dx.
So y is x to the 3/2, so
dy/dx is easy to compute,
y prime, dy/dx is
just 3/2 x to the 1/2,
or 3/2 square root of x.
So ds, then-- well, we just
have to plug it in there.
So that means ds is equal to
the square root of 1 plus-- OK.
So now you have to square this.
Well, 3/2 squared is just
9/4, and the square root
of x squared is x.
So this is 9/4 x dx.
So this is the thing that
we want to integrate.
And now you need
bounds of integration.
So in our case, this is dx.
We want to integrate
with respect
to x, so we need bounds on x.
And luckily we have them.
We have 0 less than or equal
to x, less than or equal to 4,
the bounds that we want.
So the arc length in
question is the integral
from 0 to 4 of square
root of 1 plus 9/4 x dx.
Now, this curve has
the property that this
is an integral we actually
know how to compute.
Right?
There's a-- well, OK.
So I always lose track of
my constants when I do this,
so I'm going to do an
extra substitution,
and then it'll be really easy.
But you know, this is an
integral-- many of you
can probably do this
one in your heads,
basically, at this point.
This is unusual.
Even most polynomials
that you write down,
computing their arc
length is really hard.
You get nasty things popping up.
So, you know, I
sort of conspired
to choose a one that
will have a value that we
can integrate by hand.
You don't need to resort to
any sort of numerical method.
But it happens, in this
case, that that did happen,
and that's nice.
So we can we can actually write
down what this arc length is.
So I'm going to do
the substitution, u
equals 1 plus 9/4 x.
So with this substitution, I
get that du is equal to 9/4 dx,
and since I want to
substitute it the other way,
I could write that
as dx equals 4/9 du.
And I also need
to change bounds,
so when x equals 0, that
goes to u, I put the 0 here,
u is equal to 1 when
x is equal to 4.
So I put 4 in here.
That goes to u equals
10, and so, OK.
With those substitutions,
I get that the arc length
that I'm interested in is
the integral from 1 to 10
of 4/9 times the
square root of u du.
OK.
And so now this is,
you know, really easy.
So this is u to the 1/2,
so I integrate that,
so I'm going to get u to
the 3/2 divided by 3/2.
So this is 4/9 times u to the
3/2 divided by 3/2 between u
equals 1 and u equals 10.
OK.
So I can divide here, so this
becomes 8/27 is the constant.
So this is 8 over 27 times 10
to the 3/2 minus 1 to the 3/2,
is just 1.
OK.
So now if you
wanted to, you know,
get a decimal approximation
for this number,
you could put this
into a calculator.
You can also kind
of eyeball what
this is, because 10,
the square root of 10
is just a little bigger than
3, so this is, you know,
bigger than 27, so
this is bigger than 26.
So this whole thing is probably
about 8 or a little bit larger.
Probably going to be a
little bit larger than 8,
would be my guess.
So that's, you know,
just rough eyeballing.
Since you're all sitting
in front of a computer,
I'm sure you can get a more
precise estimate on your own.
But there we go.
So very much just applying the
sort of straightforward tools
that we've developed for
computing arc lengths.
You know, using our formulas
for the little element
of arc length, for the
differential of arc length.
Computing a derivative,
plugging it in.
And it happens, in this
case, that we got something
that we can actually
evaluate the resulting
integral in a nice closed form.
So I'll stop there.